[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous c'est vous alors
tom il a un petit bonheur oui on va
expliquer pourquoi moi
oui parce que j'ai tu le sais pas ce que
tu me le disent mais voilà une autre
séquence non vous savez chez thierry
ardisson je suis je pose les questions
trop con que thierry ardisson n'a pas
voulu poser et là on se concerter avec
cyril et du coup j'ai écrit les
questions que cyril ne voudrais pas vous
posez donc il ya plein de questions sur
tous les membres à nîmes
ça peut tomber à n'importe quelle
demande et je voudrais dire quelque
chose vraiment je suis très très très
très fan de temps si vraiment je te sais
c'est vrai c'est un des mecs qui me fait
le plus rire je suis très très heureux
pour tout cela on peut l'applaudir
encore bercy alors j'ai une première
question mais il ya beaucoup de rumeurs
qui traînent sur internet c'est vrai que
jean michel lemaire en thaïlande y ait
une mst qui porte votre nom
j'adore cette émission
cette émission des martres et la
canebière ouais ouais
j'adore parce que tu fais nos jeunes
gens avaient sans déconner mais quelques
mois je suis là
lang une question pour daniel vous êtes
célibataire on en parle vous vivez chez
votre maman vous aimez les hommes plus
vieux et vous bossez danse est au
programme
ça fait pas beaucoup de handicaps d'un
coupon pouvez même
mais en plus ce qu'il faut de vraies
questions dont je suis fan de lui tu y
as oui bon quoi faire tout de suite oui
j'en ai une petite pause pour matthieu
delormeau hier cyril vous avez dit qu'il
avait un projet pour vous de quatre
prime
par contre vous étiez au courant que
c'était pour le regarder de chez vous je
savais qu'il fallait qu'on arrive
justement c'est pour rebondir par
rapport à jean michel maire jean-michel
je crois que vous avez été correspondant
de guerre en bosnie à l'époque vous
partez avec votre bits et votre couteau
du coup aujourd'hui les pas le
malheureux votre couteau et en plus
c'est arrivé mais il sait que tu as
saoudite ou le mobile tous les maux
couteau dans la cuisine normalement ces
bons sont inscrits à cette émission y'a
jean-michel voilà normand qui râlent
mobilité puis si nabil a passé le graal
mot couteau
et les mots sont couramment prononcer
dans cette émission il est en forme
je peux me permettre si j'ai une petite
question pour matthieu delormeau tout à
l'heure a vanté pmp il a présenté il en
pense quoi mathieu j'ai vraiment besoin
de répondre à cette question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]